this is the box that each head
of state has in his possession to call
his staff which is located in the other
room when one of the heads of state has a
question he has pressed the red button
is automatically on the other  side the
country that called is displayed on a
screen
there is no direct communication
with the room because it is the
confidentiality at the level of the debates
which between the heads of heads of state is
in fact so we  is in the process
of installing here according to the table plan
that we have received a button for each head
of state
everything presents one net computer to
connect journalist connectivity
network of technical limitations
with distributors of state in sum
vip room the chaos if  all their
wylfa stuff and connections